[Music]
[Applause]
former nfl quarterback of course heisman
trophy winner usc carson palmer joining
us on the program carson i want you to
listen to bill belichick this morning
and tell me if this sounds like the bill
belichick that you know
look fellas i apologize if you know i
seem like i was a little short with you
after the game um
you know obviously a frustrating game
down 20 to nothing didn't do anything
well enough i mean there isn't really
much to say at that point without
watching the film
clearly we had problems in every area
so
you know there was no
no simple answer and you know every play
could have been better every
every area of coaching could could have
been better every area plane could have
been better
and any of that would have helped so
um carson who is that guy
that's steve belichick isn't that his
son apologizing to the media phil
doesn't apologize to the media he
doesn't even acknowledge the media most
the time i can't believe i just heard
that
yeah i i don't know what happened like
of all the times when he's disrespectful
to the media whatever happened when they
lost to the colts that made him like oh
you know i got to apologize to the media
well it is the first time he's lost the
colts in a solid two or three decades so
maybe just something came over him and
some some emotions came over him that he
just wasn't quite sure how to handle and
how to let out did you see brady during
the game last night go over to dennis
allen
who was filling in for sean payton
and and he
basically says
bleep you like he has an exchange with
him how often does that happen
it's only happened a handful of times
the new york giants got a a certain
level of frustration out of brady a
couple different times of super bowls
and last night i mean they they couldn't
move the ball unless they were throwing
little tiny short passes and obviously
with all the injuries they had at
outside with their receiving core um but
i mean you saw it a little bit last year
in the super bowl with tyron matthew
when he got frustrated with tyron down
in the red zone you saw it last night i
mean they put up zero points against a a
very average to below average uh team in
new orleans i know that defense is good
but i mean that that that's the kind of
brady
you know that that
those exclamation points those bleep you
things you just don't typically see
unless you really frustrate him you hit
him you make him move off of his spot in
the pocket and that's what new orleans
did all night long they kept him
frustrated he wasn't on his game they
weren't on their game in tampa and that
defense just they just continued to eat
as the night went on and held them to
zero points have you ever yelled at an
opposing coach during a game
i'm sure i have i'm sure i have multiple
times it's just hard to actually get
caught where you can actually mouth and
see and see the words that that you're
saying to that individual that very
rarely happens but you know we you've
seen it it happened i've seen it happen
during games with brady where he's
yelling and screaming at guys that's the
intensity you want from your quarterback
that's the intensity uh you want out of
the guys you're lining up in the huddle
you just don't want to get caught on tv
with the bleep you but can you play mad
at that position
if anybody can it's brady i mean brady's
played in just about every mindset
throughout the years uh throughout his
career it's a little bit harder uh you
know when when you're exchanging words
on the sideline and just when you're
throwing out the the end of that bleep
the ck of that bleep your headset starts
coming in and here comes the next play
so you gotta really quickly
reload get whatever thoughts have been
that are in your head uh out so that you
can hear that next play because now
you're on the play clock you only have
25 seconds to hear that play get to the
huddle and relay it and he just that was
just one of those nights it's fun i mean
you know unless you're a new england fan
when he was there a tampa bay fan it's
fun to see brady get mad it's fun to see
him get animated and see him get blanked
and see him put up a goose egg every
once in a while because it's so rare
what did you think of john harbaugh
going for two going for the win against
the packers
i loved it i don't care what anybody
says he's down a bunch of guys there
everybody on defense is essentially hurt
he's down his mvp quarterback he knows
if he kicks the extra point and goes to
goes to extra time the odds aren't in
his favor
when you go to extra periods and and
overtime and you don't have your
quarterback and you don't have six
starters on defense and you're down your
left tackle and your right guard and so
on and so on i like trying to go for the
win and letting it ride and it's really
a gamble at that point but it's just as
much of a gamble going into overtime
maybe you lose the coin toss again
you're down starters on defense your
downstarters on offense trying to put
the game away there and move on and get
to next week i get it i love it
unfortunately it didn't work out this
time but i have the weapon of justin
tucker like i can't
i i have to acknowledge that that if i
get to overtime yes if they win the coin
toss there's a great chance they might
go down and score a touchdown but if we
win the toss i still have justin tucker
to put us up three points and really put
some pressure on aaron rodgers so while
i'm i'm i love that they went for it and
john harbaugh gave his team the
confidence that he believed in them i
got a backup quarterback who had one
read and he missed hollywood brown who
was wide open as well
i love justin tucker too but we're
talking about a kicker
i mean we're talking about going to
extra periods you've got aaron rodgers
and a team that's what 11 and 3 on the
opposing sideline you've got all kinds
of weapons at their disposal
you have very few weapons like you just
said you're on your backup quarterback
going into extra time
i think justin tucker's potentially a
hall of famer one of the greatest
kickers i i've ever seen but at the end
of the day i like letting it ride and
seeing if you can get out of there with
a win with one play as opposed to having
to play an entire an entire
excuse me another period after that
are you sold on the saints having a
quarterback going into next season
no no the saints will be drafting
trading something something will happen
but they will not move forward i still
you know tayson tyson hill just signed a
contract and it's a great contract to be
a weapon and be kind of that utility
knife that he can play on special teams
he can run down and cover kicks he can
play running back receiver quarterback
he will be in that system obviously with
his new contract but they will be
looking for a new starting quarterback
for sure
it feels like the colts are succeeding
but not because it carson wentz it feels
like it's their defense in jonathan
taylor
so
how do you
what are they eight and six their
playoff caliber team but i just don't
know
how much can you rely on carson wentz
carson wentz is unfortunately not the
quarterback we thought he was four years
ago i mean carson wentz is right now
what he's put on tape over the last
three years is he's a he's an average
quarterback
he's not in that top tier of five or ten
guys he's not in the bottom tier of
those bottom five or ten guys he's right
in the middle of the pack
there's some plays that that you watch
when he plays and that pick he threw
into triple coverage kind of near the
end of the game there's just some plays
you can't make
if you are a top five or top ten
quarterback
fortunately for carson they've got an
unbelievable defense i mean they have
some ball hawks they have some receivers
playing corner and safety
love their linebacker core they can rush
the passer they can stop the run that
offensive line i just wish that
offensive line was there when andrew
luck was there that was the
opposite
um but they are absolutely thriving with
with and you know at this point in his
career a very average point in carson
carson wentz's career
so
we've been talking about your cardinals
and then they go cross-country and they
get roughed up by the lines
are we headed down the same road this
year
uh
i am concerned about it seeing deandre
hopkins on the sideline i mean that that
has been
kyler murray's blanket of security i
mean there is no doubt when kyler gets
the back in the pocket and he can't
quite see what's going on he just finds
a way to find deandre somewhere else on
the he may have had him on a curl he
needs to find him streaking across the
field or taking off down the sideline
that's been a massive security blanket
he's thrown game winners like like the
the hail mary he threw against buffalo a
couple years ago at home
he's on third down he's consistently
found him last week in chicago on fourth
and two he threw him a go route where he
threw an unbelievable ball and deandre
made a great catch over the shoulder for
a touchdown
that blanket is gone deandre's not
coming back he will not be on the
sidelines he will not be suited up this
year unfortunately so
that is a huge concern i mean going in
into detroit and losing to a very hungry
detroit team that wants to make a
statement against one of the best teams
the nfc was not ideal and that was just
a blip in the road but unfortunately i
think the bigger issue outside of losing
to detroit is they lost deandre hopkins
down the stretch this is when deandre
makes way and this is when deandre makes
game-winning plays in december and into
january and unfortunately now we're
going to really see what kyler's may
made of you know he's lost some guys
throughout the year they lost chase
edmonds who they just got back
he lost larry fitz obviously larry fitz
retired last year
now without deandre we're really going
to see how great this young quarterback
is and i can't wait to watch him play
these last couple weeks his body
language is really bad though like when
things go bad and you know that carson
it's really hard to like damn that's not
my fault but i'm going to get blamed for
it
um
he's he's showing blame and i don't know
if he's aware of it but that his body
language was bad yesterday
the good news is his body language is
not jay cutler bad
it's bad
but it could be worse but no doubt i
mean when when you know that that's
something you know when you look at how
do you explain
cutler's body language
awful for the capital a and the capital
w
no doubt i mean it's bad and and i i
just look back at his short career he
only played one year in college he only
had one opportunity in college to really
be the guy and be the leader and be the
captain and be the guy that can't have
bad language and then he thrust right
into the nfl and started week one so he
hasn't had the ups and downs he hasn't
had the peaks and valleys and the
adversity
that
makes you be tough that makes you put on
a you know a winning face and not have a
losing face or have that bad body
language he hasn't gone through that as
a player yet but it's bad
there's no doubt about it you can tell
his teammates and the guys around him
since it that's something that tyler
definitely needs to work on
i can't figure out the titans and the
steelers
i thought i figured out the titans
because they were beating really good
teams
and it comes down to can ryan tannehill
win a game for you i i i thought they
had a great game plan running the ball
felt like they were going to dominate
the steelers
and
pittsburgh wins that game how do you
explain that
yeah i mean i i
i feel like they're they're pretty well
figured out tennessee is is a one-man
show it's a derek henry show and they
got away with some wins and they found a
way to win without him those first
couple weeks they found a way to lose to
some really bad teams without him since
he he's gone down
so they are what they are i mean they're
a nine and seven team you know at the
end of the year maybe they make a
playoff run maybe they can squeak in but
they're not getting past anybody in the
playoffs pittsburgh at the end of the
day pittsburgh is just not very good
they're just really really well coached
and that organization is that
organization for a reason because they
do it right year in year out through
their their history they happen to have
you know ben still you know he's still a
hall of famer he's still one of the best
that i ever played against personally
he's at the end of the road but that
team is just so well coached and and
there is such a belief in tomlin and his
system and next man up mentality we've
seen that through through his tenure
we've seen it through coach cower's
tenure before mike tomlin got there that
organization that coaching staff the way
they're built
even when they're bad that's a bad
football team there's a couple of good
players on defense
and a handful of pretty good players on
offense but that team is so well coached
that organization is so well run they're
going to win games they shouldn't and
they're going to beat some teams they
have no business beating and then
they're because they're not that great
they're going to lose to some bad teams
they're going to get blown out like they
did against cincinnati a couple weeks
ago but that team will find a way to to
be a winning team like they have every
year since mike tomlin's been there and
that's why you wanted mike tomlin as the
next head coach at usc
maybe after maybe lincoln reilly leaves
for the nfl
he's one of the best i ever played
against and i love watching his teams
play but they're just not that good on
offense or defense unfortunately were
you treated worse by the fans in
pittsburgh or cleveland
pittsburgh for sure
absolutely how so
there's there's just a hatred you walk
into heinz field there's a hatred it
doesn't matter what jersey you got on if
it's not black and yellow there's a
certain hatred and
you feel it and you love it and it's a
great great energy not that the energy
in baltimore is anything
to shake a stick at because i love
playing in baltimore baltimore is the
most college-like atmosphere they've got
the band
they've got all these festive
festivities they've got the the pre-game
intro where ray lewis and terrell suggs
would do their dances um two great great
venues but there's nothing like
especially when you're an inner division
team and you're playing for the bengals
browns or ravens and you walk into heinz
field especially on a sunday night or a
monday night game against in that
atmosphere against those fans it's like
having a 12th defender on the field
sometimes because they are so tense and
the electricity in that stadium is so
great we've seen some of these
quarterbacks kenny pickett's not going
to play in the peach bowl and
i'm curious when the playoffs expand to
12 schools
then you're gonna have some real hard
decisions by some of these players i i
don't have any problem if you know
kenneth walker doesn't want to play in
the peach bowl as a running back any
running back um you don't want to play
or pickett doesn't want to play
but what's it going to be like though
when we get to the playoffs and now
you're going to be playing in a playoff
game as opposed to
a you know the peach bowl
i i think there's gonna be far fewer
players
tapping out and saying they're not gonna
play if they're if their team is in the
playoffs now if they're in some bull
that just got named last month that we
don't know about
i i can understand a guy sitting out but
as soon as you have a chance to play for
a national championship and it is
dependent on whether you win or lose
that week i think a majority of those
guys if not 100 of them decide they're
going to play and they're going to be
there for their team and see if they can
win a national championship
always great to talk to you carson
thanks for joining us talk to you next
week
thanks dan that's carson palmer former
nfl quarterback heisman trophy winner at
usc